hey this is uh this almost seems like a
Saturday Night Live skit Fox News is now
warning there may be too many jobs too
many people might be working and this
could be a warning sign for the economy
how how is that possible well like with
everything with almost everything
there's sometimes like a kernel or a
grain of Truth somewhere up the chain in
the analysis and I'm using the analysis
the term analysis extraordinarily
Loosely and we have actually previously
spoken about this oh if inflation is up
that's bad but if inflation is down
that's also bad because it signals there
might be a demand collapse and either
way we're heading towards a recession
with most economic indicate indicators
taken to their extreme you can argue
that either very high or very low isn't
good but the new one on Fox is the jobs
report might be too good this could be
bad for the economy after spending a
long time saying where are the jobs Joe
Biden and focusing on the labor
participation rate so let's look at a
couple of screen captures from Fox News
first one uh job gains spur concerns of
rising inflation
so let's explore that how does that work
well uh the more people that are working
the more people that have money to buy
things if more people want to buy the
same limited number of things you would
expect that prices could go up it's just
there's more demand so people selling
stuff if you've got a hundred people who
want to buy your sneakers you're going
to be able to charge more than if
there's only one person who wants to buy
your sneakers okay there's there's a
there's a kernel of that there but all
of a sudden now the problem is the jobs
numbers are too good that's kind of
weird but it is Fox News it is Maria
Bartiromo after all another uh headline
America's employment crisis there are
too many job openings there's too many
companies hiring compared to the number
of people looking for jobs and they put
up that this is they call this a crisis
there's 11 million job openings but
there's only six million unemployed
people
that's a crisis all of a sudden now
remember when it's convenient to them
they say well the official number of
unemployed workers doesn't reflect the
real number because you're only
considered unemployed if you're actively
looking for a job
if you are demoralized by not finding a
job you'd still like one but you've just
sort of given up you're no longer
considered unemployed so the right loves
to say that the real number of
unemployed people is millions and
millions higher than the official number
because you've got all these people uh
working part-time who would like to be
working full-time and that's not
reflected in the numbers people who have
just given up because they can't find a
job so now all of a sudden they don't
mention that now they just say hey
there's 11 million open jobs and 6
million unemployed workers the other
funny thing about this is they insist
that immigrants legal and illegal are
coming to the United States taking all
of our jobs and making it harder for the
American Born worker to find a job well
if your new argument
is that there's a shortfall of five and
a half million people there's five and a
half million more jobs than people
wouldn't you want those immigrants to
come in to work some of these jobs so
it's all completely and totally
incoherent now there's a real economic
conversation to have here and I'm glad
to have it it's not a partisan
conversation at least in principle
although the solutions that are often
proposed become extraordinarily partisan
we've talked before
um no matter what numbers there are with
most indicators you can make the case
that at one extreme or the other it
could be bad for the economy now sky is
falling headlines get way more attention
the economists and the financial
analysts who predict crashes uh get way
more clicks than the people who say hey
you know what things will probably be
more or less okay over the medium term
when it comes to the inflation numbers
we've started to see a turnaround in the
messaging from the right the first
messaging was there's so much inflation
nobody can afford anything this is a
disaster for the economy because things
are going to get so expensive nobody's
going to buy stuff that'll hurt
businesses the businesses will have to
fire people it's going to be a recession
okay as we now have seen gas prices
decline for nearly a consecutive month
we talked about last week that talked
about that last week as the jobs numbers
continue to be really really good the
new thing is uh oh if inflation comes
down and people all of a sudden now
um stop demanding stuff and that's
what's causing the inflation to go down
we are going to have potentially a
deflationary spiral a demand collapse
and that's going to be terrible because
people aren't going to be buying stuff
and it'll be terrible terrible for the
economy it's just the other side of the
same coin when you look at prices and
inflation to the extreme the reality is
pretty boring okay the reality is it's
very rare not impossible but it's very
rare to have a recession
when you have such uh you're so close to
Full Employment and we have a steady
rate of inflation which is slowly coming
down that's an important thing that's
often not mentioned inflation has been
high and I don't
I'm not pretending that it hasn't been a
problem it's been a problem inflation
has been high but it's now for several
months been quite steady there's no
escalating inflation where it's year
over year well look it looks like it's
about eight percent it's about nine it's
10 11 it's 12. it's been kind of steady
at this High sevens low eights number
and it's slowly uh likely going to start
coming down recessions are not
particularly common in that scenario
where the employment situation looks
good and businesses generally speaking
or looking to hire and inflation is
steady is it impossible that we would
get a recession no it's not impossible
but it's not particularly likely and
that makes for pretty boring economic
analysis but it is the reality as the
numbers point to so far so the new one
from Fox the economy might be too good
for its own good find me on Twitter at
dpacman let me know if this one
surprises you
one of our sponsors today is blue chew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month's supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence when
it's time all you have to do is take a
short quiz on their website a licensed
doctor approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of Bluetooth tablets are made in the
USA the entire process is just a few
clicks go to bluetooth.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code Pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping